hales up guys my name is a cello and
welcome to episode 120 of game
programming so we're back I'm going to
try and do more episodes consistently
from now on okay I was going to do that
last time but unfortunately I got a bit
sick and was not able to do that but
this time I mean it I'm going to try my
best to to continue game programming and
actually get somewhere because it's kind
of annoying me slightly how the series
have been going on for like three years
basically and we kind of don't have a
game done yet so let's let's let's get
right on into it so this episode I want
to focus on two things right well
basically one thing I want to completely
be done with buttons okay right now we
have to kind of like that there's the
there are a few bugs and usability
issues with buttons that I want to fix
up but after that we should be pretty
much done with buttons and that's kind
of my goal right now so um basically
right now one of the bugs that we have
is it seems to work fine you can see how
the color changes when I mouse over the
color changes when I click and hold down
and then when I release actionperformed
gets run and everything seems to run
pretty well however however there is a
bug and that is if I click somewhere for
example here so I'm up right now my
mouse is being pressed and I just click
and drag you can see that it registers
as a click and then I can let go now I
don't believe we want that functionality
because as you can see if I like with
this close button if i click and drag on
here for example up here it does go it
does change the color but it's not
pressed until I actually press it again
that's kind of what we want to happen so
how can we do that well all we need to
really do is detect whether or not the
mouse was pressed when it was inside
okay so basically excuse me still
recovering from that cold but um but
basically what we want to do is we want
to say that if we weren't inside yeah so
this this this if statement here right
inside this other if statement basically
what this says is if we're inside the
button but we weren't before and we've
just pressed down right well actually
there's no such thing as pressed down
here if the mouse is inside it
inside before we're going to expand this
a little bit okay basically before we do
this we want to check to see if the
mouse was down right because if we for
example just say mouse dots in fact one
thing i'm going to do real quick is this
left mouse button pressed bullying left
mouse button down just go to bring that
out here so that we don't have to keep
checking it since we do use it quite a
bit but basically excuse me basically if
the left mouse button is actually down
we like this this case and i'll show it
to you guys means that entered while
pressed basically okay so if i run this
real quick you can say that if i press
it when i'm inside or whatever it
doesn't print anything however if i hold
it down and then enter you can see enter
while press gets fight exactly once okay
so what we need to do here is actually
have another Boing okay and that
bullying is essentially an ignore press
so private bullying at the top here as a
field ignore press or ignore pressed so
by default water that falls
okay we'll come down here we'll set
ignore pressed equal to true okay
otherwise that I can get rid of these
brackets otherwise we'll set ignore
pressed equal to false okay and
basically what we do then right is we
check for ignore pressed right before we
actually perform these kind of events
here so if if it's not pressed and
ignore pressed is also false we might be
able to combine it on pressing depressed
actually i'll i'll consider that in a
second but basically if it's not pressed
and if ignore press is not true and left
mouse button is down then we five event
I'll wait we do not now we need some way
of resetting ignore breast and of course
it's supposed to reset once we let go so
if you look at the windows explorer kind
of thing if I drag and then I let go and
I press again it should work right so
all we have to do here is actually split
us up a little bit so if pressed we want
to do this section here which was the
original right but if the mouse button
is simply equal to no button okay we do
want to set ignore pressed equal to
false all right and then that should
basically work so if we take a look at
that okay that still works fantastic if
we drag in we're not pressed if I let go
and press there we go beautiful so that
is fixed now can we combine it to be a
part of pressed I wonder because that
would actually be pretty good so let's
see the press is true when that happens
if not press press is false yeah yeah we
might be able to but unfortunately the
issue I'm saying right here is that
press actually does get reset and
presses false by default so there could
be a few issues there because really we
only want to let go if when all pressed
let me just consider this for one more
second I swords this else so there are
tents and container then press gets at
the falls and yeah we really want to
mess with that because that's a
completely different meaning and it
might break things in the future even if
it doesn't know I suspect it will now
though but anyway that seems to be fixed
right now so
beautiful if we drag in we we can see
we're not pressed even though I'm
holding the mouse button down for let go
and then press again it will work so the
API we have for this was pretty basic as
well we made a new UI button and we
added in you you I action listen you can
see we could do that just as an
anonymous class right in line with the
rest of our code we didn't even have to
split it up of course if this was in
fact if we were using Java 80 suspect we
could just use a lambda but if it was
any other language we could have just
pretty much used a delicate in c-sharp
or a function pointer and safe signals
plus so that would have been much easier
I think so instead of just specifying a
class we could specify the function as
well as having like an event handler
wouldn't be too bad but unfortunately
this java and i believe that is fixed in
java 8 but we are running java 7 i don't
want to break compatibility with you
people in fact we're actually on 1.6 cuz
i did start this in 2012 so we don't
really want to mess with that too much I
don't actually know if I've got 1.6
properly installed i guess i do know
Jerry 1.8 so we are maintaining
compatibility and that's an important
thing I don't really mind too much at
this point with 1.6 compatibility
because it's not you know the Middle
Ages anymore but 1.7 is a bit important
to me so I don't think I'm going to do
any of that fancy new stuff just yet ok
cool anyway a lot of talking but that is
basically fixed so few of the things
that I did want to make sure here is
that our API kind of makes sense right
so can I make buttons for multiple like
can I set up buttons my way basically
now excuse me uibutton listener has some
pretty good things going on here it's
got some sensible kind of defaults the
other we've we've set up basically for
the colors one thing we've made sure of
is that the button on that gets fired
when we actually let go of the mouse ok
a lot of people don't like that there is
an easy way you can override that ok you
can actually just override the pressed
button
and set it equal to perform all right in
fact you might not be able to do that
properly let's see if this works so what
was it you I bottom right so we added
that I guess because yeah that makes
sense why are you so sad um is that
correctly overridden I think so you are
actually listen all right oh no that's
an action listener my bad how do we set
these see this is what I'm talking about
when a good API here so sad button
listener is what I'm talking about i
think so excuse me button set bunless no
new UI love listener and then we'll have
the method i wanted to override which
was pressed and then what you could do
is just call button dots button dot
perform option which we will create in a
minute alright and that is just an
example i don't know why again some
people might like to do that the reason
I'm just kind of I'm almost playing
devil's advocate here just making sure
that the API is kind of flexible enough
i'll be able to do what I've it they
really want to do but basically this
will call this is how this is going to
work there's actually a bit trickier
than you guys probably think obvi I
don't want to do that when we perform
the action which is here sorry it's this
right there is a problem here because if
we call it this way we actually don't
want to perform the action like you'll
see what happens here if I actually
change the action to be something like
system dot out dot print line
action performed what's going to happen
as you're about to see is when i click
it it's actually going to pull me up in
twice okay the reason is it does once
from me on the press down and once on
the press up because it's naturally
going to do that yeah so if i press down
here it's going to do it once as you can
see and if I let go it's going to do it
again so we don't want that right
because if you have righted and you call
basically if you call perform action
explicitly ah then it should potentially
ignore the next perform action and there
should be a way you set that right and
the reason I don't want it so one thing
we could do really easily and we're kind
of going to do this private boolean
ignore action okay one one one
suggestion you might come up with
instantly might be like okay let's set a
no action to true over here right when
we hit perform action then we'll come
over here and we'll say if only if
ignore action is false will be actually
perform the action otherwise we'll set
excuse me otherwise we'll set that to
false right you might do something like
this and you might think that's great
and it is to an extent because you can
see when I press it it only fires once
but the problem is what if i press it
somewhere else like this means that
always my ignore action will be false so
consider this scenario what if I do it
on entered yeah that means that when I
enter I perform I action but it means
that if i enter and then i click
something that up for my action at all
right until the next time which might be
bad because maybe you're like oh
actually i do want to perform an action
right so how can you kind of work around
that well basically we can work around
that by actually having a separate
function function called ignore next
ignore next press ok and we'll set
ignore action to true and what that
means is that yes it doesn't mean
unfortunately you have to manually
specify bartonville perform action than
button dot ignore next press but it does
mean that it won't necessarily as you
can see be the case and looks like I um
where are we actually doing that
impressed okay so you can see that since
we never kind of pressure action it
never kind of goes red because we ignore
that all the time but that is the price
you pay unfortunately if you have that
kind of soy going on I'm actually quite
curious as to why because we're supposed
to us because we ever overrode it right
so if you do that you can call I wonder
if this will actually work I no idea is
that going to work because we did kind
of I guess it would dry it the soup is
kind of an enormous class yeah it does
okay so you can see there it works fine
alright when we let go though you can
see doesn't actually change which is a
bit interesting so that is a buck ah
well we will fix right now so you can
see buttons are very fun very fun to
deal with you I programming is always a
bit um it's always a bit it's not really
difficult it's just it's kind of it's
very verbose right so to speak so
there's a lot of things you have to
handle those a lot of things you have to
get right it's not very easy to do it's
not the the hardest thing to do but as
you can see it's a bit it's a big kind
of messy it's a bit annoying which is
why a lot of people use UI frameworks
but of course we're making everything
from scratch and we don't quite need the
functionality of large frameworks and if
you're making windows applications you
would never do this is just for like the
purposes of games right so if you're
making a game or a game engine you
usually want to have your own custom UI
and that's why I'm teaching you how to
do all of this stuff brilliant so what
are we going to do so the reason it
doesn't turn red I mean the reason isn't
go go away from red is um because I
believe when we press it where do we
actually set the color back it doesn't
seem like we do that anywhere so I'm
kind of a bit surprised as to why it
works in the first place right oh it
wouldn't know if I think we just set it
to close that's why and we never noticed
so when we exit we probably want to set
it to the
to the entered color like yes by default
I mean I don't know I mean I assume that
it wouldn't matter because if we press
it and we release it and we exit so
press it and then we exit yeah it's
going to be fine so there's really no
way you can screw so there you go so
there we go that is pretty much all the
bugs I believe fixed and you can see
we've actually over in the default kind
of functionality and placed our own
stuff into it and it seems to work
pretty well we've written excuse me I am
so sick of this car I'm serious anyway
you can see we've ever we've overridden
the default behavior and we have created
some new stuff and I think the API is
pretty good the last thing that I
haven't done is actually placing images
inside buttons and we will cover that
next time okay so thank you for watching
guys if you did enjoy please hit the
like button one more thing I want to
introduce that is new is I've actually
had a patreon for quite a while and
there have been a few people have signed
up over over the time and I haven't
really announced I don't really I don't
really share this too often it was kind
of excuse me this was kind of a thing
that I had in the past and I kind of
brought it on and off and I I just
wasn't sure really what to do with it
because I wasn't really clear on what
rewards you guys wanted and I didn't
just want to make a patreon just for
donations because i'm not really the
biggest fan of receiving donations in
exchange for nothing because the videos
that i make are always going to be free
i'm never going to charge money for them
anyway so that it just seemed to me like
you know people don't hang just for
nothing you know why would they do that
because everything you get is is free
anyway right so I have finally decided
what I'm going to do and basically I've
set up some rewards that I think are
actually quite nice so if you pledge
five dollars a month per month this is
per month it used to be per video which
i found was a bit it was a bit weird
because um you know I could release one
video in the minim in a month and I
could release a hundred so I mean I've
never done 100 before but you guys know
what I mean it's kind of even though you
can set maximum for Patriots it's it
might be a bit dodgy like some people
might be like yeah
well I have no idea how much money shown
I was going to take from me so I didn't
want to do that so now it's per month
that's the first thing the other thing
is for five dollars or more or more per
month you get access to the source code
of game programming via github so
basically what happens is when you
pledge five dollars per month I get your
I guess once the month expires or
something I get your github account name
so you send me your github account name
and i add you to a private repository
the contains all of the source code for
game programming now that includes all
of the assets okay excuse me that
includes all the assets includes the
after effects project that i think i had
with everything it's everything right
everything that I've use to make the
game that is in that project folder so
you get access to all that which is
pretty cool and then for ten dollar more
per month basically I provide support to
you personally for whatever it is you
may be doing so if you have any
questions about how to write something
if you have any requests for another
game programming episode or something
you can send me an email and i'll
definitely reply with whatever the
answer to that may be okay so those are
some pledges again they're not too much
five bucks a month i think is is pretty
fair to receive the source code of 119
episodes and three years of cherno
spending his time making videos but i
also think that over time when i bring
back other series such as game
programming sorry so just 3d game
programming which i'm going to resurrect
in an interesting fashion very soon
that's also going to fall under that
umbrella and it should generally be a
good time so if you guys enjoyed the
video please hit the like button if you
really enjoy the video you want access
to some pretty exclusive content then
you can support me on patreon link will
be in this in the description and on the
screen right now and I will see you guys
next time with some images inside
buttons goodbye
you